the boy hey Bruce
you don't mind if I just take this last
coat
oh you do my
hey big hand go through did it not
awesome
okay wow so angry no you poor sad Hulk
hold on
Wow you have the greenest eyes
hey youtubers it's Charlie so buncha
guys asked me to do a video for Hulk
ant-man from the Superbowl so just to
explain what's going on some of it was a
little confusing because you're like
ant-man isn't supposed to meet hope for
a while a lot of you pointed out that
ant-man is wearing a different helmet in
the Captain America civil war trailer
from the Superbowl than he is in this ad
that's because they started making this
ad a long time ago it takes a long time
to do special effects for Hulk so they
probably started working on it as much
as six months ago and yes eventually
Hulk and ant-man are going to be on
screen together but probably not till
infinity war hulk is currently
whereabouts unknown as of the end of
Avengers age of Ultron he has to get
into space somehow because a Thor
Ragnarok based on the rumors they meet
in a very planet hulk way where he's on
Sekar or a planet likes a car fighting
in an arena but they still have to
explain how hulk gets into space so one
of the next movies either Captain
America civil war or Doctor Strange or
black panther Marvel Studios is not a
company that is known for subtlety they
will totally spell it out when it says
this is Bruce Banner slap I know it
looks like it might be in the Avengers
tower but then when they crash out you
can see that they're just in the middle
of Manhattan somewhere so if you want to
place the Hulk parts of this in the
timeline think of it is happening
sometime before Avengers age of Ultron
in the ant-man stuff happening from
after his movie it would be really weird
if Hulk just showed up with the Avengers
at the beginning of Captain America
Civil War he's not in the movie by the
way but it'd be totally weird if he
showed up and they didn't even bother to
address where he went at the end of age
of Ultron Black Widow slaps him upside
the head I told you to call me [ __ ]
why didn't you call we get to Easter Egg
territory when they open the fridge
everything in the fridge here is
something from a previous Avengers movie
so they're just winking at you from
behind the camera you have leftover
shwarma there's even a snapchat picture
up at the top here I think that's maybe
because they want you to sign up for
coca-cola snapchat give the anger
management book here sitting on the desk
you know you just love the idea that
Bruce Banner would call a code GREEN
because someone stole his coke Minnie
like of all the things that get really
upset about all sudden he's like I'm
gonna smash up half of Manhattan caused
millions of dollars of damage because
you stole my soda that's worth less than
a dollar I do like the ant-man
acrobatics you have to remember that he
gets stronger as he gets smaller so you
could make jokes about the immovable
object and the unstoppable force but a
better example that would be the Hulk
punching the blob he has
is power called gravitational mass
allocation where as long as he's in
contact with the ground he can
essentially turn himself into an
immovable object so you literally get an
unstoppable force that gets stronger as
it gets matter punching someone that
cannot be moved it's kind of like the
reverse of him trying to pick Thor's
hammer up and obviously for the sake of
the ad they want him to open it and
drink it like a normal person would
drink it but I think if the hook was
really thirsty and did one a coke and
couldn't open it he would just squish it
with his hand pour it all into his mouth
he'd probably even eat the can but back
to Thor Hulk Ragnarok stuff and I know
he's missing as of the end of Avengers
age of Ultron but until we see otherwise
he is on earth somewhere he's just
hiding out now let me know how you think
he gets into space do you think it's
going to be one of the post-credits
scenes during Captain America Civil War
they could even wait to the beginning of
Thor Ragnarok like he could still be on
earth and they could deal with it in
flashbacks like he just he wakes up in
an arena or he wakes up on another
planet and it's like how did I get here
I don't remember
and then they deal with the rest through
flashback Marvel is getting a little bit
better about the way it does its origin
stories it's not the linear old-school
way like you know beginning middle and
usually you just pick up with the hero
doing awesome things like even during
the first Iron Man film it picks up with
him in the cave then it flashes back to
how he got there so when we see Hulk
Thor Ragnarok they might give us the
explainer in that same way where it
flashes back to hope back on earth
getting fired into space somehow and
then winding up on some crazy planet I
really am hoping they do Planet Hulk
storyline across the next couple movies
that's actually another good question
let me know what you guys think about
them breaking up a really big story for
the Hulk over a couple different movies
versus them just doing a Hulk solo film
would you rather see them do that I mean
they can still do cool stories but it's
very different when you have to weave
through a bunch of other characters
stories I think it'll be fine as long as
I keep it under control
sometimes when the movies get a little
too big like Avengers age of Ultron it
got a little too big it takes you out of
the story a little and I wouldn't expect
to get any clear answers from Marvel
about what's going on with Hulk for a
long time they've got to promote Doctor
Strange after Captain America Civil War
comes out so they'll mostly be focused
on that which is actually going to be
pretty awesome I'm probably gonna get
our first teaser for that when Captain
America hits theaters and slightly
related news there's a bunch of crazy
stuff happening on TV this week but the
flash is really going to take the cake
because we're going to earth to we're
going to see killer
frost a bunch of cool characters so
really like DZ TV will probably win the
week but agent Carter is still really
good too so be sure to check everything
out most of the Marvel stuff that I'm
going to do for the rest of the week
will be movie specific stuff but feel
free to leave requests in the comments
so why guys wait for all those videos to
post you can click here for the Civil
War super bowl trailer and you can click
here for the x-men apocalypse zilog
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight